so the first story we have is actually
you know we're getting set up for the
show and uh when when news breaks right
before the show it's tough because you
know I I'm reading the news up until
like four and then I get to exercise and
eat and so we're getting up here we're
pulling stories and it's just right
before the show we get this clip Jack
besobic posted it breaking Zuckerberg
says Facebook limited distribution of
the hunter laptop story based on a
general request from the FD FBI we're
going to play this clip for you now and
hear what Mr Zuckerberg had to say let's
turn up
news items controversial like there was
a lot of attention on Twitter during the
election because of the hunter Biden
laptop story yeah so you guys censored
that as well
so we took a different path than Twitter
um I mean basically the background here
is the FBI I think basically came to us
some some folks on our team it was like
hey
um just so you know like you should be
on high alert there was we we thought
there was a lot of Russian propaganda in
the 2016 election we have it on notice
that basically there's about to be some
kind of dump of of um uh that's similar
to that so just be vigilant so our
protocol is different from Twitter's
what Twitter did is they said you can't
share this at all
um we didn't do that what we do is we
have um
if something is reported to us as
potentially
misinformation important misinformation
we we also have this third party
fact-checking program because we don't
want to be deciding what's true and
false and for the I think it was five or
seven days when it was basically being
um being determined whether it was false
um
the Distribution on Facebook was
decreased but people were still allowed
to share it so you could still share it
you could still consume it when you say
the distribution is decreased it got
shared how does that work it basically
the ranking in news feed was a little
bit less so fewer people saw it than
would have otherwise so it definitely in
other words Mark Zuckerberg has admitted
that the FBI came to them and said hey
watch out for this uh Russian
misinformation so I went okay hey look
here's a negative story about Biden
let's censor this because people have to
determine whether it's false and people
of course are their chosen sources he's
trying to very much downplay it I don't
want to make it seem like the FBI went
to him and said outright censor the
hunter Biden laptop story which is kind
of what Maya understanding was but it's
more so they came to them and said watch
out for for you know this kind of
misinformation which triggers Facebook
to then say we're going to censor some
of these stories interfering in the
election man dark days indeed is one way
to put it yeah I don't know what are you
thinking because you're you worked on
social media stuff you worked on the
censorship stuff um well firstly Mark
ducked the question when Joe was like so
you censored it too Mark didn't say yes
but they did and what they did was they
blacklisted the thing they put it they
they Shadow banned it they they
downranked it in the algorithm which is
a you know you could say it's an
Insidious form of censorship because the
people don't even know it's being
censored at least when it won't go
through you know it won't go through
um question about ethics of it oh also
he talks about we don't want to be the
ones that decide what's right and wrong
so we Outsource that to a third party
like that so we've decided someone else
gets to decide what's right and wrong I
don't know I think the community should
be deciding what violates terms
personally well to me it just sounds
like they're Outsourcing they're
choosing who they're Outsourcing to so
they're already so they're deciding by
not deciding they're saying we're going
to Outsource this other group we know
they're left-leaning but at least it
won't be up it's kind of like what
Pontius pilot did Jesus Christ exactly
you want to wash my hands to this
publicly you know it's not me that's
that's the bad person in the room it's
definitely someone else and we're not
going to tell you who that is and kind
of bury that information but you know
censorship is good for us you know
because how we know what's true if we're
not told what's true you know you know
I'm one thing I don't like about this is
like Mark it's not a it's not a
publisher the Facebook's not a
publishing platform it's a it's like a
general platform that's allowing people
to publish their own stuff so that they
take I don't know man we're in very
strange times with new technology so
laws and things need to be Rewritten
this would be like your phone company
sending you a notice being like hey if
you have a phone conversation about
Hunter Biden we're gonna shut your call
down yeah but it's a pub it's different
because it's public so they're
downranking it's visibility which is
different than not letting you have you
could still have that call we'll just
lower the volume so everybody can hear
you but that's not true either I
couldn't do a call to a loudspeaker in a
stadium full of people I'm using that
Tech to deliver a message in a direction
Twitter was was substantially worse they
were stopping you from even sharing it
between people which is like more so
like you can't call people and tell them
this but what if I do a phone call to a
conference room maybe it's a university
with a thousand people you know sitting
in an auditorium and they and we do a
phone call so that everyone can hear
what I have to say yeah be like them
saying this your call is not going to
access speaker phones we're not going to
let any speaker phones take your calls
only only individual people can hear it
or something like that I guess the
question is turn the volume down I'll
say this too as kind of a
is this a correction on on how I opened
my understanding was that the FBI made a
request for the hunter Biden laptop
story to be censored what Mark is saying
is they gave them a general request
about hey you should basically like they
basically told Facebook to censor
information they said that Russians are
trying to interfere wink wink nudge
nudge we know what that means I think it
was more direct than that but Mark is
clearly trying to downplay what's going
on so I just want to make sure we're
clear I don't know that the FBI told him
to censor the 100 laptop store
explicitly but the FBI did go to
Facebook and said watch out for this
stuff which they know would result in
Facebook censoring tons of information
regardless of where it came from I mean
the fact that the FBI said any
information should be under under watch
is a First Amendment violation and any
action taken after that in my I would
argue is Facebook acting on behest of
the US government it's funny like We As
Americans have First Amendment rights
but do Russians have First Amendment
rights when they're in Russia using
Facebook that Americans are reading I
don't think so they have Russian rights
um so does the FBI have to give Russians
First Amendment rights if they're using
American corporations I don't know well
non-citizens do have constitutional
rights when they're in the country
that's right but not when they're using
technology when they're not in the
country but they're using technology see
it's a weird reality now where Tech you
can be in Russia but also be in the
United States via video chat and it
looks like you're here it sounds like
you're here
well as far as I'm concerned the FBI
stepping in and saying anything to this
so-called private company just removes
the argument that of course the
government's not the one censoring it's
just Facebook saying that you can or
can't share this this is 100 the
government deciding what people could or
should see and it's not even about
Russia at this point because I'm fully
convinced the FBI knew that this wasn't
Russian disinformation they just wanted
to wink wink nudge nudge Facebook into
being like okay so we'll keep this on
the down low mine's mine's frames a
little differently they say Mark
Zuckerberg tells Joe Rogan that Facebook
algorithmically censored the hunter
Biden laptop story for seven days based
on a general request from the FBI to
restrict election misinformation I think
that's a fair assessment and you need to
understand that means the government is
going to Big platforms and saying
restrict things you choose at our behest
yep we've got us there's got to be some
lawsuits or something to stop this
because you know I was reading recently
is it August 2nd state of Missouri I
think Gateway pundit I think Jim hoft
several other people are involved in
this lawsuit against a bunch of
Democrats Biden I think Biden and the
government saying that section 230 is a
law that gives special clearance to to
Big Tech to censor and and suppress
information but that is only possible
because the US government has given them
this special access which is a First
Amendment violation I completely agree
you've also got stories like Alex
Berenson
he uh uh I think it's confirmed now
right he reported this that the
government requested he be censored
specifically and then the Twitter the
government went to Twitter said why
aren't you censoring this guy and
they're like okay and they banned him
files a lawsuit gets his account back at
this point there is no argument the
government is actively playing a role in
censoring information they do not like
well I guess that's the conversation
like
we've always considered that the
government is taking information and
withholding some of it from us maybe to
protect us because we don't know what's
best for ourselves and now we're getting
more information that's readily
accessible to all of us and it's it's
making things spiral because people can
go search anything now we got computers
in our in our pockets so if we want to
learn about something we can and I think
this is just the the veils being removed
and people are getting so much
information that it's hard to stop it so
we're seeing these hard stops being put
in place it's like you ever see one of
those cartoons where they're on a boat
and then like a hole breaks and the guy
sticks his finger in the hole and
another hole breaks and then his toes
and then his tongue and then his eye
goes in that's basically what's
happening they can't stop the flow of
information and they keep trying to and
it's just getting it's making things
crazier and it's making things worse
well even so it was the Sam Harris
problem anyway they had decided that
this is our guy he's going to Dethrone
the other guy it really was a matter of
time before this was going to come out
anyway they just needed to hold it in
place just long enough for the their guy
to get installed and now it's coming out
and they can't stop it but nobody cares
now that it's coming out all the
implications of he was working with X Y
and Z and now we're sending money to X Y
and Z it doesn't matter anymore they won
yeah who was it who was just on who said
things gonna get hurt was it Amy Wolf I
think so oh yeah she's been saying that
she's like the election well that that
moving now into the midterms yeah we're
gonna see really crazy stuff like you
don't you don't know that was Mike
Glover my Glover yeah yeah he was like
it's going to get crazy as far as
Revelations no just in terms of like
like weird political stories yeah do you
have sober surprises oh yeah it's like
we're gonna see like 50 October
surprises there's gonna be like you know
nudes of old people oh no it would be
like someone's gonna be accused of
literally throwing a pie at some other
guy it's gonna be great I mean look what
they did with Brett Kavanaugh right
Brett Kavanaugh was accused of like I
mean the accusations are just laughably
insane that men were lining up outside
of dorm rooms yeah and like nobody said
anything for 30 years it's just it's
just kind of crazy to do it and and
people I I you know I gotta be honest I
don't think these people really believe
it but I don't think they're they're
Lucid to have to really believe anyway I
think they're like mindlessly droning on
and just parroting with a I just think
they're broken like these people are
just broken and they've they've gone to
a point where their party keeps moving
their line and if they don't move with
it they get ousted they get taken away
from their party so you successfully
broken half of the people and they'll
just pair it whatever they need to pair
it where they believe it or not I've got
a bunch of friends that you know a
couple years ago they had different
stances and we could have a rational
conversation walk away and shake hands
but we can't do that anymore crazy well
like the crazy thing is there are people
that I've I've known for 20 years and as
soon as like you know like the shows are
getting prominence
someone I talked to regularly all of a
sudden now is running full speed to
produce Outlets being like I I'll make
whatever up you know it's just just what
do you want to hear what should I tell
you about them and they're just tweeting
things like crazy and I'm like what the
this is weird yeah what happened with
you and your friends did you notice like
a shift we lost a lot a lot of friends
man uh like like you know 10-year
friends I there's actually a couple that
still haven't reached out to us you know
and these were people who were supposed
to be like God Parents to our children
like very very close deep friends and
you know my thoughts always been
you saw me do one thing one time but
you've known me for a decade you know
where I live if you actually want to
know you can just come talk to me it's
not about you it's about people feeling
like I just need to say what they tell
me to say because I don't want trouble
so uh the example that I think really
hits the nail in the head that I've
brought up several times now I ad
nauseum is a woman asking three other
women what is a woman
and um again I think it was I should
probably check who said because I think
it was Matt Walsh these young women know
what a woman is but they're trying to
reconcile that with what they're
supposed to say it is and so they end up
stuttering and stammering and making no
sense because it's like there's an
obvious logic and then there's but I'm
not allowed to say it yeah the fascist
word is one of those like I feel like
everybody told me he said I was
supporting fascism by doing this show
and then the other night we had Joe
latapo on who's the Surgeon General of
Florida and I'm like how is interviewing
the Surgeon General of the state fascism
that's the most insane accusation but
like people this whole like Trump is a
fascist narrative is like if you don't I
think if you don't fall into that then
you start to get left behind it's
because he is the enemy like we don't
look at each other like neighbors
anymore we're gonna look at each other
like fellow citizens the idea is you are
either with me or you are my enemy we
don't have conversations that that want
to produce relationship anymore we have
conversation that we only want to
produce I'm right and you're wrong and
if you don't believe what I believe then
you're out you think part of the is like
from follower counts on social media we
didn't used to have that now everyone's
kind of competing almost I think it's a
big component of it I think that that
kind of helps bring us to where we are
but but a big component of it is just
that you can really see now who uh
10 20 years ago you know talking about
people who are friends now you know who
actually
was your friend who actually believed
what they were saying and now you can
tell who was just saying what they
thought was socially acceptable
acceptable because they wanted
they wanted something yeah maybe it's
always been this way yeah but social
media is um it's almost like a it's a
room you can go vent in and now you're
just allowed to say it and well it's not
real there but I mean it's real you have
your opinions you post them and now we
know people for who they are and it's
readily accessible one of the positive
things happened with me is my Facebook
Instagram got nuked almost immediately
so anything bad that I said over the
past 10 years like it's gone I never
said anything wrong you can't find it
thanks for checking out this segment
from the timcast IRL podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in Monday through Friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm we'll see you all there